wir alle kennen und lieben Eric eric ist
ein fester Bestandteil von diesem Kanal
geworden wir kochen zusammen wir essen
zusammen wir machen eigentlich alles
zusammen was hier auf diesem Kanal
stattfindet eine Frage rennt in unseren
Herzen wer kann eigentlich besser kochen
dieser Frage wollen wir uns heute widmen
wir haben Brummi unseren Praktikanten
losgeschickt er hat einen wilden
Warenkorb zusammengestellt mit
verschiedensten Produkten also
eigentlich wirklich alles und das beste
war wir wussten überhaupt nicht was auf
uns zukommt so wie damals bei der
Challenge gegen Lari die ich verloren
habe mir war aber ganz klar ich möchte
diese Gelegenheit meinen Ruf wieder
herzustellen nicht ungenutzt lassen mich
vollkommen ins Zeug legen und als Erik
und ich mit verbundenen Augen in die
Küche geführt wurden habe ich mir
gedacht jetzt gebe ich alles los geht's
oder ich weiß nicht was jetzt passiert
aber abziehen 3 2 1 ich wollte das so
abreißen okay wo ist das Lamm okay wir
haben ganz kurz
lammbohnen andere Bohnen so ein paar
Pulver Kartoffeln Butter Brühe Rotwein
wir haben drei Sorten Kartoffeln ihr
wisst vielleicht das letzte Battle habe
ich ja gegen Lara gegen meine Freundin
verloren deshalb sind meine persönlichen
Ziele umso höher gesetzt heute und ich
muss das ganze mal kurz ob ich wirken
lassen und mir überhaupt zu überlegen
was ich jetzt mache logischerweise
bereite ich auf die möglichst beste Art
und Weise das Lamm zu also ist ja so ein
Lammkarree richtig schön dass sie
wirklich super aus also mit den Knochen
French dran ne haben wir verschiedene
Kartoffeln ich sehe Backpulver ich habe
da schon eine Idee und Bohnen und Speck
weil am Ende auch schön aussehen wir
müssen es schaffen dass wir uns
gegenseitig nicht so viel abgucken
deshalb höre ich mal weg wenn Eric jetzt
erzählt was er so vor hat also Lamm
übelst lecker hat Max für mich auch mal
gekocht bei meinem persönlichen Koch hat
ja auch sehr gut geschmeckt mir sehr
sehr gut geschmeckt Rotwein es sieht
alles nach einer Soße aus viel Erfolg
okay komm wie so ein Platz ne sagt man
ja in der französischen Küche das werde
ich nämlich jetzt genauso machen
die Enden einmal ab das Ding ist ich
brauche basically 2 Backöfen also ich
weiß nicht wie viele du brauchst
vielleicht geht's auch gar nicht mehr
habe ich brauche einen Backofen um mein
Lamm durchzuziehen das will ich halt
auch machen die andere Sache die ich im
Backofen machen will könnte dazu
beitragen dass ich hier heute mit dem
Sieg nach Hause gehe ich habe hier meine
Bohnen jetzt ins Wasser geschmissen weiß
ich nicht ob ich das so machen würde
also
komplett Timing ist ja in der Küche eh
nicht so wichtig nein das muss bereits
reichen Notebook mein Problem ist
irgendwie gerade dass ich so wirklich
gar keine Reihenfolge das ist wirklich
gerade sehr hart ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen zu diesem Zeitpunkt habe ich mir
gedacht das wird eine klare Sache also
ich hatte meinen Plan ich hatte meine
Vision und Erik ist zugegebenermaßen
etwas hektisch neben mir hin und her
geflitzt wie ein Flummi ich wüsste nicht
was jetzt schief gehen sollte also ich
bin auf einem guten Weg würde ich sagen
dachte ich zumindest ich habe mich
wirklich ein Schimmer wie lange das
Ganze gleich brauchen wird im Backofen
ich bin gerade beschäftigt dadurch dass
ich ein Handschuh habe kann ich nicht
gelernte Koch erkennt das eigentlich
also das hier ist Thymian Leute einfach
von allem hier ein bisschen dann wird
das schon schmecken okay Pfanne beginnt
leicht an zu rauchen und hinein mit
unserem Lamm Weg im ganzen wohlgemerkt
die Endstücke meiner Lampe habe ich
klein gewürfelt und die Knochen auch
aufbewahrt weil ich mache die jetzt hier
für meine Soße oh mashallah
das versuchen wir jetzt von allen Seiten
natürlich möchte nicht nur Fleisch
sondern auch wie rotweingült die möchte
ich nämlich gerne auch aromatisieren
schaut mal hier auf den Pfannenboden
kopfboden besser gesagt wir haben
richtig hasserösterung das lassen wir
jetzt noch mal richtig heiß werden und
dann löschen wir das gleich ab so weil
Rotwein ist drin abgelöscht kurz
aufkochen lassen riecht schon super dazu
muss man sagen viele Leute sagen das war
eine gute Soße safe also Soße Soße ist
der Weg in das Herz von Menschen ja man
möchte einfach schon reinbeißen das
riecht so gut ich habe hier eine
Kräuterbutter Mischung sage ich jetzt
mal noch herangegeben die natürlich
wegschmelzen wird aber die hoffentlich
auch Geschmack auf der Außenhaut lassen
wird Backofen auf boah das ist zu krank
ne das ist wirklich zu krank ich packe
meins hier auf meiner Seite nach links
gepackst eins auf deine Seite es ist
interessant weil wir kennen beide diesen
Ofen auch nicht ne wir müssen jetzt zum
ersten Mal in der Zwischenzeit kann ich
vorerst erstmal nur weiter warten die
brauchen eine Stunde im Ofen irgendwie
ist ja klar dass wenn ich jetzt rum
stehe und die ganze Zeit nichts tue das
auch ich noch ein bisschen in Hektik
verfallen werde aber mein Zeitplan stand
wie gesagt Halt und ich konnte zu dem
Zeitpunkt nichts anderes machen als zu
warten dass wir endlich unser Alarm in
den Ofen tun konnten damit ich mit Soße
und allem drum und dran weitermachen
konnte mein Experiment hier mein
einsamer Kartoffelwürfel der so da vor
sich hin brutzelt law and slow
wohlgemerkt und mein Test war
erfolgreich ich habe auch die anderen
Süßkartoffeln dazu geschrieben haben
jetzt noch einen Würfel geschnitten
irgendwas muss ja mit meiner Zeit machen
das heißt hier mal mein Wasser ich komme
nämlich jetzt zu den Kartoffeln und
aufmerksame Zuschauer meines Kanals
haben vielleicht schon eine Idee in
welche Richtung es geht nimm mir einen
Teelöffel Backpulver füge ihn in mein
Wasser ihr seht schon direkt da geht die
Magie los falls ihr euch fragt was ich
jetzt mache ich koche meine
Kartoffelwürfel vor aus dem ganz
einfachen Grund
normales Wasser mit Salz ist sauer und
was ich gemacht habe ist dass ich
Backpulver hinzugegeben habe wodurch das
Wasser basisch wird klingt jetzt alles
sehr abstrakt aber ich habe das gelernt
bei einem meiner lieblingsköche und das
hat zur Folge das Pektin also der
Ballaststoff in der Kartoffel der die
Kartoffel zusammenhält so der sie hart
macht das bist Du bei mir übrigens dass
der sich schneller abbaut dass der
schneller abgebaut wird was zu einer
weicheren Oberfläche führt was wiederum
bei meinen Röstkartoffeln zu mehr Crunch
führen wird soweit die Theorie ich hoffe
ihr fandet diese Animation genauso schön
wie ich das ist ja eine Sache mit der
wir eigentlich weniger arbeiten leider
aber heute haben wir ein ganz besonderen
Partner der genau solche Sachen
ermöglicht deshalb vielen lieben Dank an
Adobe die mich in diesem Projekt in dem
heutigen Video und mich aber auch schon
seit vielen vielen Jahren mit ihren
Produkten unterstützen zu Creative Cloud
gehören Produkte wie premier pro
Photoshop Illustrator Dresscode oder
After Effects somit können wirklich alle
Projekte jeglicher Art umgesetzt werden
für Schüler Studenten Azubis und Lehrer
gibt mit 65 Prozent auf Creative Cloud
den Link den ihr sucht findet ihr in
meinem angepinnten Kommentar und
übrigens ihr könnt das Abo 7 Tage lang
kostenfrei testen um euch einfach mal
mit der gesamten Bandbreite
auszuprobieren deshalb nochmal vielen
vielen Dank an unseren Partner Adobe und
weiter geht's mit dem kochbattle ich
werde jetzt meine Süßkartoffel probieren
so Kochfeld hinten schnell angeschnitten
wie schmeckt eine Süßkartoffel Eric sehr
lecker Backblech gebe ich zum Vorheizen
mit rein deshalb gehe ich runter von der
Hitze das reicht auch schon das ist
jetzt schön aromatisiert mein Öl das
muss passen ich packe mir ein kleines
Sieb ein feines Sieb ein kleines feines
und sei ihr hier einmal mein Öl durch so
dass die harten Bestandteile draußen
bleiben und das flüssige aromatisierte
Öl im Glas landet meine Kartoffeln sind
jetzt fertig ich hatte gar keinen Stress
damit das Ganze festzustellen ich musste
sie nicht mal probieren ich habe mir
einen Timer gestellt und diesen Effekt
jetzt noch weiter zu verstärken davon
dass diese Oberfläche jetzt schon so
leicht weich geworden ist gebe ich mein
aromatisiertes Öl drüber und bewegt die
hier drin so ein bisschen ihr kennt das
von meinem Kanal das ist ein absolutes
favorite kartoffelrezept dass ich habe
jetzt beginnt das ganze schon das bildet
sich hier so diese kartoffelpüreeartige
Schicht auf der Oberfläche aber das wird
fast wie so ein kleiner Teig Mantel
meine Kartoffeln kommen jetzt in den
Backofen ein wenig Backpapier hau die
Dinger rein und gucke dass ich hier alle
gleichmäßig verteile so dass die
gleichmäßig Luft bekommen hier spielt
mir jetzt auf jeden Fall die Karten dass
wir nur diese eine Anrichte Portion
machen weil je mehr man rein macht in so
einem Ofen desto weniger knusprig wird
es sollen wir mal schauen wie es bei
unserem Lamm aussieht
aber man sieht auf jeden Fall schon hier
das Rad durch und ist auf einem guten
Weg hoffentlich eric ist gerade an der
Tür und der stellt einfach auf meine
Seite in den Kopf das geht nicht ich
brauche den Platz ich wollte dich gar
nicht das war intuitiv die Pfanne gebe
ich jetzt meine Schalotte hinein in
niedrigere Hitze meine gehackten Kräuter
mal wieder eine jui braucht ja auch Zeit
hier in mir ein bisschen zu schnell
deshalb ablöschen weil ich bin so
gespannt auf diese Typ Alter ich habe
wirklich kein Zimmer
ich verrate euch eine Sache die ich
gemacht habe ich habe meine Butter in
den Kühlschrank gestellt also ich werde
gleich später meine Soße montieren dafür
muss die Butter kalt sein aber ich
kriege die mehr diesen Glanz und sowas
ich glaube das könnte auch ein wichtiger
Punkt für meinen Soße sein für ein
bisschen eifersüchtig auf deine Bro also
auf deinem Fortschritt weil es so
gesehen habe sah schon echt gut aus der
Rotwein ist jetzt so zu zwei Dritteln
verkocht jetzt gebe ich mal meine Brühe
dazu was man sagen muss wir haben ja
alles außer so eine dicke die Erik schon
in seiner Soße hat meine kocht halt
einfach schon
denn ich mache einen
Kartoffelpüree und die Würfel und die
Würfel ja
ein bisschen dein Name drauf
Kartoffelpüree mit Süßkartoffel Würfeln
so daran könnte Lara am ehesten erkennen
von wem was ist
ein bisschen was von Lasagne mit
Schnitzel falls ihr euch erinnert das
ist einmal hier oben dran das sieht gar
nicht ach so super wenig aus was wir
hier haben beim besten Willen auch nicht
viel aber man sieht einfach das ist fett
das ist Geschmack das ist genau was wir
brauchen junge Junge ich brauche dieses
Gefäß hier und ich brauche dieses Tuch
mit der Soße wirst du es tun du willst
das Tuch einfärben nicht ich schütte
meine Soße durch das Tuch ja und dadurch
ist sie klar klar das ist wirklich gut
schön ausbringen wir möchten ihr das
noch so kleine bisschen an Flüssigkeit
haben die habe ich mir gerade schon in
Soßen top sauber gemacht und da schütte
ich jetzt ein kleines bisschen süß
hinein was noch viel weniger wird ist
halt wirklich eine Herausforderung jetzt
eine echte jui zu machen weil als ich
die gemacht habe damals habe ich halt so
10 Liter Flüssigkeit auf 50 ml reduziert
das macht es nicht nur leicht aber ich
bin stolz darauf dass sie klar ist macht
der denn jetzt schon wieder egal ist
schon komplett free eric ist einfach so
der ist nicht in der Küche
Labor ich blanchiere auch meine Bohnen
hast du mal deine probiert nein die sehr
sauer bei dir auch schon viel Säure weil
der hat so viel weint reduziert haben
überrascht mich und spätestens jetzt
nach dem abschmecken der Soße wusste ich
es ist doch nicht alles so einfach ich
habe ein ziemliches Problem weil die
Soße ist super flüssig sie schmeckt
sauer und hat nichts mit der Soße zu tun
die ich hier in meinem Kopf hatte
deshalb habe ich ein paar Sachen
probiert ich habe jetzt den
Kartoffelpüree mit meinen bereits
ausgelassenen schön angebräunten one
Schale Stückchen vereint das ist das
Geschmack Bruder
sehr ungewohnt aber sehr lecker Bohnen
sind fertig blanchiert ich habe so Angst
ne ich würde so vor lauter Säure am
liebsten so ein bisschen Milch
hinzufügen zu meiner
jetzt hier so kleine Pakete paar
Böhnchen Rolle ich das ganze ein einmal
durchschneiden fertig geht auch nicht
verkehrt aus schaut euch was aus der
übrig geblieben ist es ist ein Hauch von
Nichts und das versuche ich jetzt noch
hier von diesem ganzen Zeug zu trennen
und es funktioniert das ist hoffentlich
mein Sieg normalerweise muss man sogar
kalte Butter hinzufügen ne wir haben gar
keine kalte Wasser wir haben sie
kaltgestellt zu Beginn der Challenge
shit hast du es gemacht krank das ist
meine ultra geschmacksbutter aber du
bist wirklich am Experimentieren einfach
so was ich jetzt mache kalte Butter die
kalter Blödmann
oh die süß sind so unterschiedlich aus
Mamma Mia ey also meine Süße noch zu
flüssig leider und ich habe glaube ich
zu früh angefangen sich zu montieren ich
hatte erst einen dicken müssen dann
montieren man 24 letzte was man macht
Punktlandung rufen Kartoffeln sind
fertig den Ofen mache ich aus Resthitze
bleibt noch zum warmhalten und Ernst
happy Bros mit einer Jean also ich habe
das Problem das hier bei meinen Jü
versucht eingedeckt das hier ist nachdem
ich noch mal erhitzt habe das hat er
total so Knötchen gebildet und sieht
halt überhaupt nicht mehr so aus wie der
Grund weshalb ich durch das Tuch
passiert habe
weiß ehrlich nicht macht alles keinen
Unterschied mehr dass ich halt jetzt
geteilt weil nach dem Montieren erhitzt
man so eine Jünger natürlich eigentlich
nicht mehr weil sich dann quasi die
Butter wieder löst und an der Oberfläche
absetzt was ziemlich genau das ist was
passiert ist man kann ja wenn sich Öl
und Flüssigkeit trennen zumindest
versuchen sie zu emulgieren mit Gewalt
das gebe ich meine Kräuter wieder dazu
entweder klingt das hart oder ist kein
knusprig Zutaten das ist ja ein
kompletter fail da ist nichts mehr drin
wir richten an jetzt ich richte eine
wenn ich jetzt genau das geschafft hätte
was mir vorgenommen habe dann würde ich
jetzt mit Herz mit Freude aufräumen aber
es ist einfach nur so die Farben und so
sind nicht verkehrt immerhin kriegen wir
das noch hin
[Musik]
perfekt finde ich ist nicht so geil so
rötlich ne mhm
[Musik]
ich bin miese unzufrieden durch ich bin
nicht hundertprozentig zufrieden ich bin
mir aber ziemlich sicher dass es
schmecken wird
du darfst gerne kommen jetzt Larry oh
wow das sieht beides sehr gut aus mich
persönlich lachen da immer total die
Garantie potatoes an sieht das beides
sehr gut aus hier ist natürlich noch mal
die Soße Soße ist eigentlich immer im
Pluspunkt ja ist ausgeglichen würde ich
sagen dann gehen wir mit der Geschmack
entscheiden Gleichstand in den tastest
ich werde jetzt einfach mal so eine
Kartoffel als erstes probieren das ist
ja das was mir als
man hört schon schmeckt so wie es klingt
nur ein bisschen kalt oder was meine
Schuld probieren wir jetzt mal das ist
Lamm oder
[Gelächter]
ich probiere direkt im Kontrast dazu mal
den anderen Teller man sieht nicht so
gut da aber gut Fett dabei hier nehme
ich jetzt mal ein bisschen von dem ich
schätze es ist Polenta nee
Kartoffelpüree ich weiß es nicht und
vielleicht Süßkartoffel
sehr geil kann ich nicht so richtig
enträtseln was das ist aber lecker
probieren wir jetzt mal die
sehr sehr knuspriger Bacon gut direkt
daneben mal die anderen schmeckt
frischer als das ich bin großer Fan von
crispy-kartoffeln deswegen hätte ich
wenn es auf einer Speisekarte gestanden
hätte wahrscheinlich eher das hier
bestellt ich gebe beiden Gerichten acht
von zehn neun von zehn was schätzt du
denn was ist von wem ja du hast dich
nach hier gesetzt
nein
mal schauen aber weißt du was mich die
ganze Zeit geärgert hat wir haben die
gleich zubereitet was noch hier von der
Kruste geschnitten also Loki müsste
Erics in der Mitte genauso aussehen wie
meins Loki nicht weil ich glaube meins
ja glaube ich länger gegart und von
allen Seiten tatsächlich hä Meter also
man kann das Safe essen aber ja mach das
gerne
mutiger Bissen man kann es nicht hoch es
ist Medium perfekt Medium und das ist
ein airway done oder
das ist aber das sieht anders aus also
bei mir ist der Grand ein bisschen
dicker aber ja er Regie ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen es war sehr sehr viel
Arbeit und es wird noch mehr Arbeit wenn
wir das ganze sauber machen wie gesagt
wir gucken mal ob Erik seinen Job noch
behalten kann und das letzte Wort hast
als Gewinner du auf max Kopf ist eine
videoempfehlung speziell für euch und
genau damit ihr mich als Verlierer nicht
mehr ertragen muss abonniert den Kanal
ciao
[Musik]